zum ersten mal hat die menschheit die
möglichkeit ein 4 6 milliarden jahre
altes objekt im weltraum zu untersuchen
die raumsonde rosetta wird auf einem
kometen landen der genau so alt ist und
sich seitdem nicht mehr verändert hat
damals ist unser sonnensystem entstanden
und mit den besuch auf diesen kometen
werden wir einen blick zurück genau zu
diesem zeitpunkt werfen können jetzt in
kick zum science fiction
denner seit 69 entdeckten die forscher
vor ihm auf und der asi menkow einem
kometen der sich auf einer elliptischen
bahn zwischen jupiter und erde bewegt 24
jahre später beschloss die europäische
weltraumorganisation esa das projekt
rosetta also den flug mit einer
unbemannten sonde zu genau diesen
kometen zum ersten mal sollte man dort
landen
im märz 2004 wurde die raumsonde auf die
reise geschickt kostenpunkt eine
milliarde euro mehr als sechs milliarden
kilometer die sonne in den vergangenen
zehn jahren zurückgelegt dabei wurde sie
die ganze zeit mit hilfe von solarzellen
betrieben um energie zu sparen wurde sie
sogar knapp drei jahre abgeschaltet und
schließlich wieder erfolgreich
reaktiviert
das ist keinesfalls selbstverständlich
da über die gesamte flugdauer keinerlei
wartung möglich war
das heißt zehn jahre nach dem start
funktionieren noch alle instrumente so
wie sie sollen
und rosetta ist jetzt angekommen sie
umkreis den kometen der kaum größer als
ein deutsches dorf ist drei mal fünf
kilometer so ungefähr und rosetta
kartografiert jetzt erstmal die
oberfläche des kometen in den folgenden
wochen beginnt die wirklich heiße phase
des projektes die wissenschaftler wollen
den viele länder die landeeinheit der
sonde auf dem kometen landen und diverse
versuche durchführen
deshalb ist die landeeinheit mit zehn
verschiedenen instrumenten ausgestattet
dazu gehören beispielsweise kameras die
alles genau dokumentieren eine bohr
einrichtung für eine probe der kometen
materie aus bis zu 30 zentimetern tiefe
und verschiedene chemische sowie
physikalische tests probleme bereitet
vor allem die zusammensetzung des
kometen 67 ps mio moov gerasimenko so
heißt er oder kurz 760 b es ist nämlich
ungewiss ob die landung auf pulver
schnitt oder hartem eis stattfindet das
ist gerade die größte herausforderung
dass wir auf einem kometen landen wollen
den wir noch nicht kennen meint stefano
lameck der viele projektleiter beim
deutschen zentrum für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr der viele länder wird
übrigens direkt hier aus köln porz
gesteuert nur wenige kilometer von mir
entfernt sind natürlich schon eckdaten
bekannt größe ungefähr wie ein dorf in
deutschland er hat ein sehr schlechtes
reflexionsvermögen und brauchte 6,4 5
jahre
um die erde zu umkreisen nebenbei
bemerkt aufgrund des schlechten
reflexionsvermögen muss jede aufnahme
von 67 p sehr lange belichtet werden
also wenn der komet fotografiert werden
soll dann kann das bis zu zehn minuten
dauern das ist fast 30.000 mal länger
als ein normales foto hier auf der erde
so düster ist es da draußen zudem weiß
man dass der kommerz zwei verbundenen
teilen besteht ja so ein bisschen aus
wie die gummi ente in der badewanne
das meinen die wissenschaftler ja und
die landung die gibt es dann im november
und das wird ein hartes stück arbeit
denn der komet hat eine viel zu geringe
anziehungskraft deshalb wird die sonde
erst mit einer kalt gas diese auf die
oberfläche gedrückt dann werden zwei
happonen abgeschossen
in die oberfläche um sich zu fahren kann
und am schluss drehen und schrauben sich
die füße in den boden rein die haben ein
gewinde extra dafür am ende und dann
sind wir auf die ergebnisse gespannt
kommt nieten und hass zu ihnen
die sind übrigens eine gefahr für die
erde vielfach unterschätzt wenn euch ein
sehr spannendes video dazu interessiert
dann kriegt ihr drauf und mehr
wissenschafts news die gibt es in der
app und auf dem blog dafür
hier klicken und ja wo bin ich hier hat
es gemerkt das ist die lanxess arena in
köln
kleiner hinweis noch es gibt noch
restkarten aber wirklich nicht mehr
viele für diese wahnsinns show am 15 und
16 8 mit allem pipapo einem ganzen tag
lang nur community day also der hammer
und was meint ihr zu dem thema was wir
gerade gesehen haben werden das
spannende ergebnisse werden wir mehr
über die ursprünge des sonnensystems
erfahren oder ist die milliarde für die
katz gewesen diskutiert es mit mir in
den kommentaren und ansonsten wema bis
dann bleibt dran